Lego group as we mentioned not that far
removed from near bankruptcy last month
you told an audience and Connecticut
quote we had become a company that did
not listen to our customers and quote
isn't that rule number one in business
what happened pretty much so I mean we
had probably had too many years of
consecutive success prior to you know a
decade ago and had become a little bit
too introvert and probably also a little
bit too you know ignoring the needs of
our customers and our consumers what did
the company learn from its mistakes well
exactly what we've been leveraging the
last ten years and as you alluded to
we've now had the 10th consecutive years
of growth in the US and part of that
success comes from actually really
understanding the needs of of children
making sure that we have products that
are relevant to any age and states of
children did you have focus groups of
kids did they tell you what we have
focus groups of kids all the time well
but but maybe we were filtering that in
a different way than we used to or we
are filtering it there in a different
way now than we used to and really
listening with a different year because
focus groups you can either listen to
where you can really listen absolute and
I think we taught ourselves to really
listen to make money you had to spend
money which areas did you target we
spend a lot of money in the product
development side we spend a lot of money
with our retail partners to make sure
that the the execution of the label
brand at all level as well as online has
become really interesting and appealing
to to shoppers and children you are in
an industry that is constantly evolving
what are you doing to keep up were you
being challenged we yeah I don't think
right now we're actually really being
challenged I think we're enjoying the
time we have right now we're having fun
I think what is really the key to our
success is that constant listening that
constant being in tune when kids want to
move into the digital space how do we
move into the digital space with
children instead of trying to ignore the
digital space how do we go into
storytelling when kids wants to go more
interest Oratory and it's really been
been part of the success from the Foster
the LEGO Friends that's a new line
that's aimed at girls it's been growing
20% a year since it was introduced in
2012 why did it take so long for the
company to break this gender stereotype
I don't know if it's a house it's less
of a gender specific aspect but it's
more a question of actually really again
listening to predominantly the girls
side and then figuring out what needs to
they have in the play process that might
be different
it's a typical boy and from that we got
some fascinating insights in terms of
how they how they play more in smaller
process steps than a long building
process and then the roleplay dimension
has to be interjected in between and as
you said it's been a it's been a
fantastic successful we really proud
Rhonda are you surprised at how
successful it's been no I'm proud about
it but I because we did our homework we
did the two insights and admittedly we
failed in the in that space you know
three or four times and from every
failure we learned and got a little bit
sharper what did the girls tell you they
wanted they wanted that different
building process they didn't want to
build for too long they liked the
building the core building Lego plays
exactly the same but it's just more in
smaller steps and then roleplay in
between they wanted a slightly different
looking figurine so play with is also
probably the two very it seems very
simple now yeah but obviously getting to
those insights took a lot of hard work
sir you mentioned the digital age just a
moment ago how has that changed your
approach to how toys are made and
marketed it's definitely changed how
it's marketed and it also is changing
how it's being played with you know the
digital space has been important for us
ever since we introduced platform games
with no Lego Star Wars games on Wii and
Xbox and Sony PlayStation years back and
we're already there we saw that by
allowing kids to play a lego experience
in that environment entice them to come
back and do even more under hands-on
minds-on because at the end of day we
are not a digital company we are
hands-on minds-on tectile company or
product is and by figuring out how we
can allow children to interact
seamlessly between those two worlds is
one of the ways that has been very
successful what does it mean for you
personally to see a child playing with
Legos to see the creative process
starting to take hold because I see that
with my own son where you see sometimes
they'll go away from the install
and they make their own toys and then
you're thinking engineer you're thinking
architect you see the wheels starting to
turn we most of us go to work at legal
group go to work every day with a
mission to inspire the builders of
tomorrow we believe in the importance of
development creativity and allowing
children to use their imagination so
seeing that focused moment we call it
the Doyle building the product creation
so it's immensely important to us that's
why we go to work every day before I let
you go I have to ask you the movie site
Fandango it can tuck a conductor to
Poland this year's Oscar nominations the
lego movie was cited as the top omission
right what's your reaction to that I
think everybody thought Best Animated
Feature Legos got to be a sure hit right
you know I don't know what goes on in
Hollywood I'm not an expert in that but
I did you say somebody else said that's
okay we'll build our own lego Oscar do
you I think one of the directors that
they built oh yeah we but they built
their own the Oscar and you know for us
we had huge success with the lego movie
and be proud about that and that's as
important to us as any award they're
going to be sequel there will in 2018
Wow nice